[Musique]
ces agents de la direction des moyens
généraux au département prépare des
colis contenant des masques de
protection et les acheminerons ensuite
dans les centres de protection
maternelle et infantile pour être
délivrés aux assistantes maternelles
astrid meilleur est elle-même
assistantes maternelles sur saint denis
elle est venue aujourd'hui récupérer ces
masques de protection mises à
disposition par le département des
mesures de protection reste de vigueur
le département est en mesure de
contribuer à la mise en place de ces
gènes barrières de protection en
justement distribuer aux incidents de
maternelle un lot de 40 masques par
personne et la procédure on va dire à
mettre en place pour que ça se passe au
mieux et le plus rapidement possible
c'est que les professionnels prennent
contact avec le centre de pmi auxquels
sont rattachés afin de fixer un rendez
vous est de pouvoir venir chercher les
masques qui leur sont réservées voilà
les gestes barrière s'applique à
l'arrivée dans le centre de protection
maternelle et infantile
des précautions qui s'instaure également
lors de l'accueil des enfants par les
assistantes maternelles
on a déjà la désinfection comment des
jouets de tout l'espace qui est plus
pointu dès que les enfants s'en vont
comme je disais à madame maso aussi pour
que les parents arrivent le fait de leur
faire rôtir les chaussures pour les
parents à l'extérieur les sacs les
vêtements pareil on essaye de les
vêtements que les enfants arrivent avec
les vêtements on les met dans un sac
moi personnellement je re déshabiller
les enfants je remets des eaux de
vêtements le temps qu'ils sont à la
maison et le soir avait changé on voit
là mais il ya des protocoles qui sont
petit peu plus dans la continuité des
actions engagées par le plan masquer le
département continue la distribution de
ces équipements de protection à ces
publics
toutes les assistantes maternelles en
activité disposeront de ces masques
elles devront prendre contact avec leurs
centres de pmi et convenir d'un rendez
vous
[Musique]